welcome to the Saints the first rule of
drew brees is you don't talk about drew
brees the second rule drew brees is that
when you do talk about him you mentioned
that he's a great football player but an
even better man
oh but many of you I was stuck I'd go
through seven and nine seasons and
wonder how do these consistent passing
records define me as a person that pray
for a different life I want you to line
up as a receiver what I want you to line
up as a receiver what if we did wacky
stuff on offense all the time thus began
Project Mayhem did you go for it on
fourth down wait time someone beat the
Rams and a question everyone is asking
Who Dat our offense is getting too
dangerous we have to stop this sorry sir
we must do everything to completions
his name was Desmond Bryan his name was
Desmond Bryan oh come on back coach
Taysom Hills taking over he's running
he's passing he's blocking he's that's
impossible nobody like that exists you
were looking for a way to stop being
boring and great so you made me up so
you could be interesting in great
everything's gonna be fine
hi sports fans please subscribe to this
channel or not it's okay you can also
watch more episodes here but only if you
want to sorry for bothering you